[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm red and I'm
Rhett ah I got you
I'm link I think you got yourself I
fooled you man
well is that why we introduced ourselves
at the beginning of the podcast widow
that wheeled me we know who we are is it
for them yeah I would have gotten for
the loot if you can't get me if I go
first this is a fundamental
misunderstanding if I said welcome to
ear biscuits I'm linked I would have
gotten you but I already said my name so
you saying that you're Rhett is getting
no one you know what I was at the
mythical beast I'll get you next week
okay I'm ready
I'm gonna get me there's nothing you can
do to prepare well now I know that
you're gonna do it I am prepared I'll
still get you okay I'll still get you
this week at the roundtable a dim
lighting we're asking the question what
is the greatest game show of all time at
least according to me and separately but
equally according to link oh that's
funny don't say that he's funny
you can laugh or don't but don't save
that sweetie we have real insulting
we have ranked our top five game shows
and we haven't looked at each other's
lists and made a list of honorable
mentions because it wasn't necessarily
that easy to do that so we're gonna
we're gonna go through that compare
notes now and can I just say that you
you may say oh who cares about game
shows I don't even know why I'm
listening to this but I will say I'm
personally offended because this is a
deeply personal topic for me like as I
think will become clear very quickly
when I go through my list game shows are
tied in not only to my psyche and not
only to by the way what we do for a
living now in terms of format in good
mythical morning I think there's a lot
that we don't we haven't plumbed the
depths maybe we will to date of how
games the game show culture and our
experiences with it have shaped good
mythical morning but even if we don't
get to it it is a fact mmm
but even more importantly there's a
certain part of my childhood actually a
couple of errors in my childhood that
would
deeply associated with with game shows
well and I also think it will be
interesting because my theory is that
your criteria for what makes a good game
show is probably different than mine and
we can just maybe there ends up being
some crossover because of that maybe not
or maybe we'll just fight so I am
excited about this discussion we do want
to let you know that we are coming your
way if you happen to be in one of the
following places on the following dates
yes
again this musical comedy tour that
we're doing right now which is not the
tour of mythicality people are still
calling it that the tour mythicality was
a distinct thing that was related to the
first book this is a musical concert
experience that we're having Britton
Buchanan links cousin from The Voice
open enough for us and anecdotal
evidence as told to us by mythical beast
that we met while on tour last time have
told us that they prefer this show to
the tour of mythicality so I would say 8
out of 10 9 out of 10
maybe 10 out of 10 yeah there was a
couple people right there was a couple
people she attend dentist prefer yeah
especially if you're a dentist rhett and
Link live concert in concert versus the
tour of mythicality but he liked that
you'll love leo and again didn't like if
you're lovely we're gonna be in Las
Vegas on Friday June 21st we're gonna be
in Salt Lake City on June 22nd we're
gonna be in Denver Colorado on June 23rd
we're gonna be in Milwaukee on June 25th
Indianapolis June 26th Detroit on June
27th Omaha on June 29th and Minneapolis
on June 30th come out and see us and if
you know someone who's in these areas
tell them to come out and see it because
that's what we run into what we what we
have found is every time we were
visiting a town and we're walking around
before a show or after a show or
whatever people are like rattling what
are you doing here and we're like well
we got a show and they're like what oh
we had a show that's even sadder yes so
we're letting you know now so you can
let them know now go to rhett and Link
live.com to get your tip
get your ticks you got something for me
before we get it yeah I do
I'm feeling not a little bit jittery
because I am does that mean not jittery
or a lot jittery I am a lot jittery I am
on sort of this the second half of day
two and I'm not gonna say the brand
because I haven't finished this yet so
I'm not in the mood for an endorsement I
don't know if this is going to be
something that I will then recommend to
other people but I you know I like to
try new things and experiment with new
things and I'm kind of into the whole
like this is a if this is illegal we
should talk it's not illegal I'm into
the whole anti-aging thing and you know
I've been doing the intermittent fasting
thing for almost two months now which is
basically eating for an eight-hour
period and then not eating for a 16 hour
period super actually a lot of people
here are doing it at the office like
it's really popular that makes it a
better item sure it actually no so
here's what I'll say I can give it Lisa
think a two months in endorsement of
intermittent fasting has radically
transformed some things about my body
and I'm not talking about like body
shape I'm talking about like
inflammation like I got like little
spots of like psoriasis that pop up
those have dwindled I I have like this
this recurrence sort of like on like
unpredictable bowel reactions to things
you know like if we eat something weird
on the show or if we eat something
really spicy that has stabilized and all
the five times that I've had hot chicken
in the past couple weeks absolutely no
negative effects from it oh yeah I have
to believe that this is somewhat related
you've been freed up to say yes every
single time that you're remotely
presented with the opportunity to sample
a hot chicken listen and we're walking
down the light to me and I said I'll
meet up with you later I'm gonna be in
this hot chicken place that we just
happen to stumble on even though we've
just eaten lunch and getting like the
hottest one still no effect and this is
again this is not the thing that you're
not endorsing this is interim
it just means you're waking up in the
morning you're not eating breakfast you
eat at you you you pick an eight hour
there's different I'm doing the 16 and
eight so basically I wake up in the
morning I don't eat until noon and then
I don't eat after eight o'clock and I'm
in basically the kind of client would be
easy but I I don't think I could wait
until noon to eat well I get it wasn't a
I was never like I don't wake up hungry
so that wasn't a big deal for me what
about when you if you go to the gym and
then after we're not you starving and
you have a built muscle yeah but you
were just pretty pretty quickly to that
and it doesn't you drink right
you drink drink water and you just water
yeah or you have tea you just and you
can take there's some people who are
really like really sticklers and who are
like you can have like some like BCAAs
like you know branched chain amino acids
and stuff like that that they don't
really hit the cat the calorie okay
you're losing me that kind of thing it
for me that's really complicated because
I don't want to be the dad who doesn't
eat dinner you know I'm saying so this
way I can still eat dinner which makes
me not a weird great movie though okay
the dad who would not eat dinner it's in
black and white but um you get used to
that after like the opening scene which
is amazing it's the dad and he's at the
table but he's not eating dinner right
but he's present everybody else is there
eating dinner he just watches you as you
eat yeah it's and it's it was hilarious
better than just like watching TV while
you eat I hated him but that's the start
a show so you have a difficult time in
the morning late at night this is that
is my time that's what's been difficult
to me is I am a late night snack er and
so stopping eating basically at eight
o'clock essentially after dinner that
has been a difficult adjustment of me so
I go to bed hungry but you haven't you
haven't even gotten to the thing but the
thing that I am trying now is this thing
is called the fasting mimicking diet
that these professors are a professor at
USC like partnered with some anti-aging
Institute and they came up they
formulated this diet that makes you feel
better it's a five it does well it's not
just some hack it's like scientific from
a legitimate establishment they bait
they formulated you guys see a oh no
that that tricks your body into thinking
that it is fasting so when you fast all
this stuff happens like all the science
is showing right now that during a
period of fasting there's like all these
things that are happening to your body
and organs shrinking and cell renewal
and stuff like that that they're
beginning the research is beginning to
kind of line up that this is a really
healthy thing for people to do but
fasting just cold turkey is a difficult
thing to do and also also probably I
don't really know all the reasons why
they they want you to have a little bit
of calories but not go cold turkey but I
think that it's just an easier
transition for people I like systems
like that I can just get a box of food
yeah yeah and just be like I don't have
to think about this I literally look at
a picture like a little printout I do
like that you get you have to eat the
three things from you get a little box
for every day's these three things at
breakfast these three things at lunch
these three things in the afternoon yeah
so cooler can do it but the things that
I'm eating are like a bar and I'm not
doing the fasting mimicking and the
intermittent fasting because I have to
keep up with the breakfast lunch and
dinner just so you know had to switch
gears try all that to say that it's not
enough food well I looked over your
shoulder yesterday and you were
finishing a bowl of like juice with
seeds in it so what it looked like to me
soup I just put it I put it in there
yeah I put it in any like suit land it
was jelly like well it the reason the
reason you interpreted it as a drink is
because I had it in a mason jar but it
was minestrone okay it wasn't it was
initially good minestrone actually it
tasted excellent in the state that I was
in but yeah you're basically doing a
hospital recovery mimic diet like when
you know if you're recovering for
something and then they have put you on
this weird bland watery diet well and
there's packs of the reason that a lot
of people including you wouldn't be able
to do this is that one of the things
that you get twice a day is a pack of
Olives oh God and actually I've never
had so much fun with a pack of Olives
what have you been doing with it well
just eating it believe it or not
and it's like six olives and it makes I
mean I already like olives but when
you're barely eating anything a package
of six olives is heavenly I mean I might
just have our little small packs of
olives then here on out you eat the pit
you're that hungry they're deep pitted
or they're yeah because they're afraid
that you'll eat it I mean here's the
thing about fasting I think goes back to
like hunter-gatherer type situation
where you're like you know you get
desperate to find some foot you're like
hunting you're out there and you're like
your organs are shrinking and your
body's getting sinewy and you're like
you're like pulling back your bowstring
and trying to trying to get a deer male
that is know what you're desperate but
that is the science behind it is that
people say that and again I I don't know
I haven't read enough about this to make
any endorsements or say what's true and
what's not true but I read about it when
you can eat it when you could just do it
the thinking a behind the whole fasting
thing is that humans traditionally like
back in those hunter-gatherer days it
wasn't like you didn't have rolling over
and stuffing your face that's a three
square meals per day you ate when there
it was plentiful that's one of the
reasons we have such a we abuse like
fats and sugars because it wasn't
awesome that you came across fats and
sugars if you came across a catechol or
a calorie dense thing you ate it
capitalized butter but now we're just
surrounded by calorie dense things and
so we're all out of whack anyway I but
my problem I think the risk with this
with the fasting is that you might find
yourself attacking and eating things
let me better watch out like if you
tried to eat Jade I would kill you like
I would not hesitate it would be
instinctive again it would be like one
of those I'm not gonna be like a
hunter-gatherer fight to the death I can
make a prawn don't eat my dog I am NOT
going to cartoon I'm gonna kill your dog
in the next four days looks like a
cooked turkey by no I will not kill your
dog eat your own dog man in in these
circumstances but in the apocalypse in
desperate times if I've already eaten
someone else's dog
and the only thing left is your dog in
my dog I'll probably your dog yeah I
think in an apocalyptic situation the
dogs that you want to keep around or
like the ones that are like ferocious
you don't want to keep around leti like
idiom ocean aport dogs like I think I
think they become like emotional support
dogs are the first things that become
like hunger support dogs right well
there's I don't watch The Walking Dead
anymore but there's not a dog in them
show right well was there a dog there's
a lot of there's a lot of Union
stipulations when you bring in the dogs
and the kids right I think that's why
they started killing the kids too early
on they killed the kids I'll tell you
right now because they have to bring in
tutors and stuff I'm I'm I'm jittery I
can only imagine how bad your shakes I
think I probably have equal shakes to
you right now I'm steady ISM as a
painter why you moving so much then for
those of you listening we're holding our
hands next to each other seeing his
shake here pretty even right now anyway
I'll report back I'll let you know how I
feel at the end of the week why not at
the end of this episode let's just
contain it right yeah yeah well I'll
still be on day two all right so let's
get into our our game show list now that
I've thoroughly picked apart your um
your minestrone diet but first we want
to let you know that you can grab the
Hat that link is wearing or at least one
very much like it at mythical dot store
these mugs are also there the well
nothing else that you're wearing
currently or that I'm wearing is
available there but there's a lot of
stuff available the pen or that pin you
got to be in the mythical Society to get
that pen that's right
mythical dot store for all your mythical
needs I think someone was just pointing
at his nipple oh no well the shirt
you're wearing nope no well listen we'll
sell anything if we can so just go over
there and
whatever it is now lots of stuff
mythical nuts to wrap you boys internat
Ament supported happening go for it go
for it and come back full I don't like
red it's at the end of an eight hours of
eating right give me your philosophy of
how you chose these I I'm a guiding
principle my guiding principle for my
top five game shows of all time was
enjoyment factor coupled with I just
think sentimental slash personal
connection so do you want to just you
wanted to start yeah well I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna give okay that's sure if
I have some honorable mentions yeah I
should ask what's your philosophy sorry
I'd have asked and and this is that's
that's what polite people would have
done and great cuz I figured that it had
to do cuz you talk about game shows a
lot especially like when you were a kid
watching interestingly watching game
shows and not watching any movies that
everyone else on earth was watching
which if you're wondering why link
didn't see Back to the Future Top Gun
Ghostbusters Goonies fill in the blank
every single movie that you saw when you
were a child he was watching game shows
well I was watching no I was watching an
Entertainment Tonight yeah my mom and I
watched entertainment at night every
single night at 7:30 I guess it was
maybe 7 o'clock yeah there was a there
was a point where during the summer mom
would drop me off at Nana and Papa's
house and Nana just worked like a few
blocks away as a dental assistant no one
was watching me but Nana would come in
at lunch like she could leave the dental
office and come home and like make lunch
for me and her and then Papa who was
police officer a chief of police he
would also come home really which many
come home and we'd eaten lunch together
so and then she would be home pretty
early in the afternoon I don't
how that happened but the dental stuff
kind of slowed down around 3:30 it kind
of like school or something I don't know
really
so um but in the mornings I would go I
would I would watch the USA Network and
they would just have syndicated game
shows like they from years earlier so
like from that so I mean it was the late
80s when I was watching these game shows
but they were from the early 80s or
seventies and I would watch reruns of
The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson
right when I would get there on USA like
that's how I watched Johnny Carson every
single day like learned all his bits and
everything about that so those are all
world and he runs from the 70s but in
that ish but at the time his show was on
at night tonight yeah it was which I
didn't stay up and watch his like a you
know an upper grade schooler and of
course because we were friends with Ben
Yen he would stay I would stay if you
spend the night at Ben's house you
stayed up and you watched Johnny Carson
yeah cuz Ben just had those kinds of
tastes I never spent the night at Ben's
house by the way really
never once yeah it's like I mean you
guys were that much you were a lot
closer than we were it's like so yeah I
would hear about Johnny Carson and
Letterman he also like Letterman but
yeah I watched the older Johnny Carson's
because they were syndicated on USA
Network and when those were done the
game shows would begin for like they
were I mean probably at least three
hours of game shows so like six game
shows some of them made my list some of
them made my honorable mention luncheon
mention any of them because then but
that's how I know what I don't know your
list yet that's special to me and so but
that was your awareness of games oh yeah
related to that summer whereas I think
that my my experience with game shows is
probably I think it represents most
people's interaction with game shows in
that I watched them when they came on in
primetime
or in the afternoon or whatever I saw
those reruns but I think my list is
generated it comes from the game shows
that I actually enjoyed personally and
with my family and I think that the ones
that I just kind of noticed this after I
compiled my list the ones that I had put
as my top 5 the thing that I value the
most about game shows is the play along
ability okay and it's interesting
because I think it was I value so I
think then I would say that you don't
value much as I do that don't I value
something else more and I've learned it
from looking at my own list only after
I'd made it so let's start with your
number 5 I have honourable mentions
maybe they're on your list number 5
Wheel of Fortune wheel of fortune Wheel
of Fortune is one of the most the
longest-running game shows in history of
course it is the the the nightly
follow-up to Jeopardy I don't why am I
saying this like you don't already know
who wouldn't know this stuff potentially
thee or potentially the most popular
game show of all time if not tied with a
couple other ones that might have made
our lists I mean it has all the
ingredients right it's got a charismatic
funny host it's got a vase has Vanna
White so it so it has the it has the sex
appeal
oh yeah of a Myrtle a woman from Myrtle
Beach South Carolina
I wonder what dress she's gonna wear
today right and I bet they're sequins
all over her dressing room I bet you
couldn't vacuum him up for going through
this like glitter no no no sequins are
way better than glitter but for her I'm
just saying they're like deeply
ingrained I bet she has sequins on her
skin I think she likes feel she had them
attached at some point right I think
Vanna White skin is sequins so if
something rips there's still sequin on
it there yeah I think that's what it is
it has a very high play a play along
ability factor yeah and accessible it's
very accessible the rules are really
easy to understand no English in words
and everyone thinks that they can do it
unlike jeopardy right everybody's
interesting everyone sure we'll talk
about Jeopardy but anyway I and of
course I you at one point so Pat Sajak
of course was a a weather man before he
was the host of the Wheel of Fortune he
was a los angeles-based weatherman I
think I've told I would I would love to
meet him and I am my dad kind of in my
mind looked like Pat Sajak and I swear
to as a kid yeah there was a time when I
was watching the weather and I told my
mom I was 100% convinced that my dad was
on television oh yeah it but they make
him up a little bit different for
television so it just look quite the
same this is when I was in eighth 38
years old couple years ago she used to
turn the letters manually no she would
light up and then she would have to walk
over there and turn up and now they
light up and then when she touches them
they change how do you think she does it
but I don't think she does anything I
don't think what I think there's this
someone who times it well I don't think
it's a touchscreen I'm just making that
note but but okay especially back when
she used to turn them she did it so
quickly if it's a huge phrase how does
she know so quickly what letters to go
to is she is it because I'm seeing it
somewhere else
is there something do they do something
that only Vanna can see on the letters
the glass well I'm not talking about
like augmented reality they definitely
didn't have that back in the eighties
they ain't even how do you think she
knows Fellman and I I agree I only just
light on lit up and then she would just
turn okay yeah but now they light up
when she touches them no they light up
and they light up and then she touches
them yeah same okay sir job is super
easy yes you're kind of in my mind I was
like how does she know to do this I said
I think I don't want to I don't want
good they just light up belittle what
she does because she does a lot she
still has a very important she walks and
she touches letters that if she didn't
if she wasn't there they would still be
revealed right it's the touch of Vanna
it's the touch of Vanna that
oh he said they still would be revealed
well I'm sorry I'm I believe that
vanna's touch is what reveals I just
remembered another game show man into my
hmm I I have to go on my top five no I
can't
it's an honorable mention okay so will a
fortune did it make your list or did you
already tell me this wheel of fortune
didn't make my list as an honorable
mention hmm
if they still had the thing at the end
where you could take your winnings and
shop remember that a like a thing would
open and then all of a sudden there'd be
all this stuff of price tags yeah and
you could shoot a spring the shopping if
you can do the freaking shopping they've
they've hold it down so much that like
well they've just taken away the
shopping if you that's all they've owned
no they also at the end it's like the
final puzzle is like RS T Ln e let's put
those up there we know you're gonna
guess those anyway for decades people
would just guess those that's not a fine
tuning so now you're like I mean it was
inevitable you have to do that but I
think someone if there's someone
time-traveled from like the van a
turning the letters physically days to
now no shopping spree none it
I'd be like they'd be very disappointed
but like wow this is yeah that's too
much changed too fast you have to slowly
evolve a game show to keep that audience
I mean my page it'll watch it it's just
really it's an indictment of us as a
society that that it's had it has to be
so it has to be so streamlined but I
think it being too hard didn't make my
list I mean it's I would love to meet
Pat Sajak and we've said it before we
want I want to go on as a duo yeah like
friends ups when they do the friends
episode yeah
Rhett and Link's we're friends we want
to go on wheel of fortune come on Pat
come on Vanna
I'm sure Vanna that you do a lot more
than we realize and we're sorry I
thought that your system for selecting
the letters so just so you know you do
I bet she's the one writing all the
puzzles by the way yeah I would love to
go on I will do nothing but positive I
will be number one on my list if we get
to be on it okay all right Feldman this
just in
in order to get the job done right vana
is given the answers to the quizzes for
the puzzles in advance so she knows
where the letters are locally she's
given but they still light up even so
she does remember one time when she
turned around the wrong letter and the
puzzle had to be thrown out see one time
he never remembers lying around the
wrong letter and she but she does know
that the solutions to the puzzles ahead
of time yeah hold on temple as they just
light up guys there's something else
going on we're going to watch clips of
this my number five is a game show that
I watched on the USA Network in that
time frame is a kid bumper stompers you
ever heard of this is that when you're
trying to do the license plate you
should probably guess but do you
remember yeah that's what it is I'm not
guessing I'm trying to remember if
that's the right thing you see okay it's
where they is it's light know if you
would have seen it it's like the vanity
plates and you're trying to figure out
what they mean yeah and I couldn't
remember who the host was I looked it up
this is like a Canadian game show that
they syndicated out du Bois oh yeah oh
boy what a Canadian name well it's the
French from Montreal al du Bois yeah I
love the bumper stumpers and I always
thought man one day I'll be able to get
a vanity plate and then when the time
came I was like ain't getting no vanity
plates extra yeah cost extra it's extra
yeah and it is extra I already just
remember loving it I mean I just think
it's simple I think it needs to be
recognized more I think it's something
that you play all the time it's
difficult to come up with a good vanity
plate in real life but how much more
difficult is it to create an entire game
show where it's like you're making it
happen this is fun that's your actually
your they turn they turn vanity plates
into an entire game show at Hannah okay
first of all that's a feat man credibly
high play a long ability factor you know
because and when people are guessing
it's like it's kind of fun to watch them
like trying to sound it out what else
happened I don't remember at least you
could win a car right I remember that
there were a lot of car sound effects
hurt hurt
I like sound effects that's all I don't
know good it only asked me anything else
I don't know what else is gonna be a
hair list if you like sound effects I
wanted it to be recognized that's my
number five What's Your Number Four not
bumper stuffers believe it or not
Hollywood Squares Hollywood Squares is
my number four we've ended up talking
about Hollywood Squares quite a bit as
we've like actually tried to figure out
what like a modern-day version of
Hollywood Squares would be because you
had the celebrity factor and of course
those are you don't know Hollywood
Squares is essentially tic-tac-toe two
people are playing tic-tac-toe against
one another and you are the way you get
a your letter either X or o on the board
is the host asks a celebrity who is in
that spot a question and then you have
to decide if you're going to agree or do
they answer the question and then
they'll yeah you have to agree or
disagree and they're in there either you
know purposely bullying you
yeah or they are answering it correctly
and you have to judge the personality
and of course for many years because
that Joan Rivers was the middle square
yeah yeah which is the most important
square I got to jump in here and say I'm
pretty disappointed
pretty disappointed or a couple of
reasons okay I'm disappointed that it's
not higher on your list and I think I
think it should be and I think it will
be after I talk some more about it
alright but you also saw my thunder oh
okay that's why I'm also upset I'm sorry
this is my number one ladies and
gentlemen my number one stealing my
thunder this is about no one the way we
do the system is that there's no build
up to number one because the chances of
the other person putting it lower it
really takes the wind out of a reveal
that just that just makes it more fun we
get you know it's just you get to the
exciting thing earlier it's like putting
the shopping spree at the top of wheel
of fortune well they should have tried
that maybe it'd still be on the air no
I'm just kidding it number one game show
is Hollywood Squares okay and I watched
I watched this religiously I'm pretty
sure it was on that you
say situation yeah I mean it was it was
soaked and I didn't realize why until I
guess now that I think about it or when
we were talking about it about a year
ago because we were talking about game
shows and idea developing ideas for game
shows honestly the comedic factor the
fact that like someone could
intentionally try to deceive you or
there's different ways to play it
some people were just celebrities and
they were just plain at sincere some of
them were acting sincere but they were
playing you and some of them you you
know the comedian's on there like Jim J
Bullock I don't know who that guy is
except that he was on Hollywood Squares
he would you know you knew he was gonna
give a funny answer yeah and and then
you weren't supposed to take it
seriously everybody would laugh and then
he would give his answer that you were
gonna agree to disagree with so this is
something we do on our show I mean when
we play our like white board games we
talk about well we kind of know that
sometimes we're gonna we're gonna
sometimes we give funny answers on the
white board sometimes we say funny
answers but then there's a different
answer on the white board like I was
gonna say so-and-so and maybe try to get
a laugh right all that comes from
Hollywood Squares and that's why I loved
I I love I mean I I love all that stuff
about it I also love the fact that it
was lower pressure for the contestants
like something about me watching okay
this is interesting this is what I
wanted to talk about so Gloria yeah and
I think I'm just now realizing this I
also love the fact that like I feel like
I could be a contestant on that and not
not just my pants and this has a lot
about our personalities because the
reason and I figured that it would be
higher on your list you have a chance
and you know and I know how to play
tic-tac-toe the reason that it did not
get higher than four on my list is
because there's not enough at stake it's
not truly competitive there's no there's
no drama like yeah I now when you get
when you get to what my number one is
you might be like well why'd it why's
that you never wanted I'll try to
justice
but the reason Hollywood Squares as
great as all those things that you
described about it I think I know what
it is but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
say it because I don't want to spoil
your number one which well you might
entice pulling it anyway I would never
do that
just fun yeah it's just it's only fun
good X's and O's Doren I don't remember
any of the contestants there's no like
do you remember when Ken Jennings was
winning for a month you know right like
there's no opportunity for the
contestant to excel in a way that brings
the attention back to them which again
is somebody who's super competitive and
is yeah had a life of like competing in
sports and stuff like that and try and
drawing attention to myself I'm
naturally kind of lock into the game
strategy and like well how do you win
this and how do you power you the victor
in this and how many squares didn't have
that it had the comedy side which I love
and that's what it's all my top 5 of all
time but it's not higher because of that
in the resurgence of game shows the
primetime game shows where you tell my
like that what's the how I'm into a box
show do learn oh do I hope that's not on
your list it isn't okay it is an
honorable mention I mean it's but I have
a very specific reason why it's not on
my list all right again I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna waste my weight one so I'm
just gonna name show that is my modern
game show and tell you why it is on my
list and what Deal or No Deal is not on
the drama and the stakes and like the
spotlight and all that stuff from all
those primetime shows the resurgence of
game shows in primetime is based on that
but it's based on the principle of drama
and cut steaks you can't get a primetime
game show that's just fun doesn't right
right right like they tried to bring
back the gong show which is not on my
list even though I watched that some and
I didn't like that because that was just
frivolous right that was that was
basically just like a crazy variety well
I wasn't it brought it back with Mike
Meyers there's no silly that no one
watching network television understood
there was a character yeah it was weird
wrong wrong crowd what is it my turn is
your turn to say what your number for it
my number for is the price is right I
think The Price is Right is the
longest-running game show in history can
you verify that at another point in my
life when I was younger and I couldn't
be left alone for any amount of time my
mom took me to miss Dean miss Dean's
broker big blue Cadillac that only had
two doors but the doors were so long it
was like you would pull the door handle
and I was like a grade schooler she
picked me up from school she pulled the
ID pulled the door handle open and then
I would have to walk in like a circular
radius in order to use it all my weight
to like push the door open and then get
in the back seat with three or four of
the kids is it the longest-running game
show yes since when
69 1972 over the syndicated version 56
is been originally aired and that was
Bob Barker from the top I believe no he
says we should have done some research
who cares about race who cares this is
all about my pudding now over the summer
when she didn't pick me up from school
and I have to like walk her door open
mom would just dropped me off and I'd be
there in the morning eat a little rice
krispies with a bunch of sugar at it and
miss Dean she added sugar to your rice
krispies at misty I insisted upon it
okay I remember there was a little
television situated like right in front
of her table where we would where we
would eat breakfast and everything and
then but then I mean we watched other
stuff but then ultimately Price is Right
where come on at the same time it does
now yeah 11 o'clock is interesting that
it's you know that's its timeslot and
that's what you associated with a
watching price is right in the late
morning but don't watch wheel of fortune
or Jeopardy in the late morning
I love prices right I also think it has
a heavy influence on good mythical
morning but what would happen is the
reason why it's not higher for me even
though I love it especially that big
wheel man that is awesome
um and I love Bob Barker I love his long
microphone at the end of the episode I
knew we were eating lunch like she would
serve lunch at like 1140 and we would
eat like our grilled cheese or whatever
and then I knew at the end of the
showcase showdown that like I'm gonna
have to take a nap right after this and
that's the reason why it's not higher
she wouldn't make us take a nap it seems
a little unfair
at noon to prices right I mean was it an
hour-long show an hour-long show and at
the moment yet you'd have a winner of
the first like first person would spin
the wheel be like oh I like that guy
he's gonna come back at the end and then
they bring more people up so at the end
when he was like and remember have your
pet spayed or neutered I was like I know
I gotta lay down
and act like I'm going to sleep I hated
it yeah that's the only reason it's not
higher but um have lovi in response to
Bob Barker's neutering call the
pandemonium when you would like run down
come on down I was this exciting well
okay so it's it it's not on my list and
it was and I ended up knocking it off to
add another one that I don't have miss
DeWitt make you take a nap at noon which
is misty cruel I never even met her you
never met her I don't think so I man the
more to think about it like it has so
many great elements oh just let me just
cover them for a second right very funny
a quick-witted host you got the sex
appeal of a lot of the Barker beauties
there's male models now now there's male
models yes it's 2019 of court rate bring
it on you've got a play along ability
you've got the variety of all the
different games you've got lots of cash
and prizes it's an hour long you've got
the wheel you've got the showcase
showdown it has like a little mini when
a safecracker comes on you get excited
of course Plinko like whoa it's like I
honestly think that the reason it didn't
make my list is that is the time of day
that it comes on yeah makes it feel less
weighty to look and the commercials
really bring you down lots of
commercials there are also lots of
they're marketed towards people who are
dying and also honestly I never
I always found myself being annoyed by
the contestants in a way that I was not
annoyed and you know what something that
Bob Barker did their manic yeah their
contestants are manic and and and he
also even though he was headed to some a
lot of dry wit I feel like he let well
he encouraged a lot of that whereas
other hosts were kind of she goes down
he almost absorbed it as personal
adulation and I don't know if I was
jealous I don't know what it was but
there was something about the whole
system that turned me off enough to make
me not because one of the reasons I've
one of them the criteria for this list
is if I turn the channel to it which I
still do turn the channel sometimes I
know what's up there for you now that
you you watch if I land on it I will
keep watching it until it's over and so
the price is right is something that I
would tune out of I didn't have to watch
it until the end so most of the stuff on
my list or all this stuff on my list is
something that I'll I will kind of lock
in to Drew Carey Drew Carey's whole
career changed it was a complete career
change to then to step into that role
what's your next one I'd love to bet a
dollar though you know just I just Dean
she's been on there she was on there
course a cast who they look at everybody
in line I hate to break this to you but
when you stand in like that they they
decide who's gonna come up they cast you
based on they pick people in line when
you're standing in line for Price is
Right they're interviewing people going
down the aisles pro/con now they're
profiling you they interviewing you and
they bring you up there it's like oh
we've got a social media get up here
girl okay I have this is my one modern
game show Who Wants to Be a Millionaire
this is okay this is the one that
recently was the was started the new the
the resurgence of game shows in
primetime I believe so dramatic and I am
talking about the Regis Philbin version
yeah yeah I don't know is it Meredith
Vieira still long I don't think it is no
and here's why
in syndication but meredith vieira took
over during the daytime okay so maybe at
night I don't know when it came on I
watched it the stakes were so high yes
you could win a million dollars unlike
anything that had ever happened on a
game show before it was nerve-racking
there was a spotlight on this person
they had to call the right person they
had to make the right decisions they use
their lifelines and then you've got this
incredibly funny host you know you've
got that so it isn't like you have this
like there was the weakest link and he
had that really like British caustic
woman British woman uh and she was she
was very funny but it was just all bit
it was all a bit the whole time in Regis
he just always liked it I always like
Regis yeah and I like to see a lot of
your dad and Reid right he always what
do we got here even started August 16
1999 so anyway still in syndication of
course all in a high playability factor
play long ability factor and the reason
that I put that on the list is because
it has all this elements the reason I
did not put Deal or No Deal on the list
is because that whole thing where they
make an offer to you and they like act
like the woman up there the silhouette
of the woman and she's on the phone and
she's talking to Howie yeah I don't like
all that stuff that I know is just all
for show you know I'm saying there was
something about the simplicity of this
person in a chair and these questions
and a few different things you could do
to get the answer and you either keep
going up or you go it was over
sensationalized but it wasn't like a
farce it wasn't a farce and there's a
farce in Deal or No Deal and also I got
to give it to Howie because I really I
really think that he was amazing on that
show I mean yeah absolutely it's an
honorable mention like it's not in my
top five yeah I didn't put it anywhere
but I got to give it to how the his like
the winking drama that he brought to it
well no he had a window a is a genius
playing into that thing I so good man he
was I mean and the fact that like a
comedian coming in and doing that but
like the comedy wasn't how dramatic he
was you know it was that he actually
wasn't it funny in the way you thought
he was gonna be funny
hmm it was he was funny and like a in a
dramatic way you know yeah but I think
it might be funny for you to watch it
because you know that he's acting with
these people too that might not be the
way every everyone no of course not
interact with but it worked on that
level so and of course he knew that in
it so anyway and I didn't again nothing
against Meredith I'm talking about the
Regis Philbin version because Regis was
funny he was first and I just don't
she's not she wasn't trying to be funny
I don't who's just trying to be nice I
don't know what she was you know but I'm
just saying she wasn't trying to be
funny Regis is a comedian and so there's
just something about how unique she was
funny
you need that voice in there I don't
think she was trying to she was she
trying to be funny did you watch that
there's so few meanings you female game
show host like all of that like 70s and
80s bravado stuff which you know now is
almost intolerable I think it's like so
I'll give it to Meredith in terms of
like being a champion of like that and
of course don't you try to make you
trying to make me look bad no I'm sorry
I know nothing to do with it she wasn't
funny just know you're sick he was not
trying to be funny
she's not trying to be funny she's eight
she's an anchor she's a news anchor
she's not a comedian so I'm saying that
she was and you need a comedian in that
role to make they'll give the full
package for that show in my mind when
she got rid of that it was like I'm not
interested anymore my number three I
might be stealing your number one here
okay my number three is family feud
that's my number one that's your number
one mm-hmm
but I don't think it is your number one
because
I'm saying family feud hosted by richard
dawson okay family feud hosted by
richard dawson was awesome
family feud hosted by ray combs was
awesome
I don't know family feud hosted by the
guy who was the beard on home
improvement that's not not good that's
the that's an improper use of the term
the bearded guy the bearded guy is
better but and then Steve freakin Harvey
Steve for Harvey is amazing
the reason that this is my number one is
because it has stood the test of time
yeah and it also has stood the test of
the Internet Family Feud unlike any
other gameshow creates amazing fodder
for tantalizing internet compilations
yeah of answers and response it's very
host and it's just always fun it's it's
fun but it's but you're not just getting
it from professional comedians like you
do on Hollywood Squares you're getting
it from normal people really racking
their brains to come up with what three
people out of a hundred said like right
that's when it gets interesting do you
believe that by the way do you believe
they're actually going out and they're
asking a hundred people stuff there
there are people that do surveys man I
think sometimes those people who they
ask are writers
well sure that's what I believe and it
doesn't matter because there's a hundred
people it's just a yeah they rack their
brains and they trap them in these
places where they have to say
embarrassing sexually-charged well and
they've in the last decade or so they
really have leaned into the innuendo
like yeah that's and they're actually
doing it for the internet clips in fact
sometimes Steve Harvey will be like you
gonna be on YouTube but you know I said
like he says it on the funny and he's
great the way that he he is great man
that's his that's his place that is
calling and there's just something about
the group this is another thing the
group effect like you
you got to come as a family so you have
to like bring the weird brother the
weird uncle like you hey you have to you
got to have five people and you freaking
and you feel the we're Russians went on
there with the weird one down at the end
did that really happen
yes it did that's correct it's the best
the best game show man
when Snoop was on there oh that's a clip
you can keep watching yeah exactly so
it's okay
unlike you know Kanye and the
Kardashians go on wheel of fortune when
you can't really I guess I think he went
on more than one Kim and Kanye could go
on together but there's a reason that
celebrities are clamoring Inc and I add
myself to that list of people who I want
to go on that freakin show let's face
off my family goes here family okay you
got one extra no I don't I need an extra
I've only got four people in my family
to bring the dog you don't have to bring
somebody anyway it's again it passes the
test of if it's on I'm gonna watch it
and I think it it depends so much on I'm
not gonna seek it out but if it's on
I'll watch it no yes no but that's but
that's you flipped through and you find
you find something I was at a restaurant
get out on YouTube I was at a restaurant
recently and uh when we were skiing and
like this restaurant was playing the
family feud I was like you gotta figure
it out I don't want to see necessarily
like the latest baseball game show my
family feud man and it's so like the
host has this is another reason I like
it is that I always secretly wanted to
be a game show host and see and like see
myself in that in that role and I see
the way somebody like Steve Harvey does
it and I'm just like mmm that's that's
it he's got it he's doing it
he'd the way he's interacting with these
people it's perfect and so I I kind of I
love watching that process happen
Family Feud FF number one I love the way
that those answers used to turn manually
it was very satisfying what do they do
now it's just screen boring I used to go
ding and turnover yeah like it was very
satisfying the way I would work all
right so you I need your number
knowingly Oh number two you need my
number two jeopardy jeopardy now why you
like jeopardy jeopardy is not on my list
is not on my honorable mentions but it
is a state whenever I go to Namie's they
would always be watching it I mean
there's so many people that are that
watch it for completely different
reasons obviously
it's completely different than family
family oh oh it is so dry yes it is just
smart people you have to be very smart
to qualify to be on Jeopardy
you can't just there's no you don't just
pay a fee or something you have to pass
a test but why to be on Jeopardy I knew
one guy who was almost on but I haven't
known anybody who's on there was a rumor
for a long time that my granddad was
gonna be on Jeopardy I remember that
back when I was a kid is like grandpa
McLaughlin it's gonna he's out he's
gonna be on Jeopardy might be on
Jeopardy I was like okay cool
I didn't like it as a kid what why I
don't understand the broad appeal of a
show that is so heady that is the appeal
it's I think it's because you get the
answers just as quick right after the
question so it you don't have you don't
really play along like I remember no no
you play along the appeal is trivia it's
the only game that's based on predicting
what a hundred people are gonna say in a
survey to a question is not trivia but
jeopardy is trivia it's like this
category I don't you know Greek
mythology like you're like oh you learn
fascinating what do I remember about
that and I think everyone is accessing
their knowledge base and I think there's
just a lot of people that a like to play
along with that to be like well what
kind of gory we're not picking how much
do I know about this and can I get the
answer before they get the answer
without you know in Groundhog Day having
seen in a million times but also seeing
somebody do what a guy like Ken Jennings
and apparently there's a guy that just
did it again
and I haven't been watching breaking the
records of of winnings yes yes
seeing somebody dominating that way just
because they are just smarter than other
people is something that people like to
watch I like to watch that's why it's
number two the way that he's winning so
much and this has been done before is
that they skip around in categories to
keep everybody on their heels and they
try to find the daily doubles early
knowing that they're not going to be the
low values and then they they're really
smart on what to wager and you can wager
everything you've got and take risks
earlier and really assert acquire a big
lead and if you don't get it right you
can recover because you're still you're
still in charge of the game and
everyone's on their heels and so that's
kind of a known game it's a known
technique now yeah I'm I'm just
fascinated with people who aren't like
heady thinkers still like to witness
trivia answers it's a different you know
I I think that's what it teaches me is
that like you don't have to be like a
reader or like honestly a very
thoughtful person to really to to also
to really enjoy bite-sized trivia it's a
different thing well I actually think
that most people who like it do you
think of themselves as they they like to
whether they are are they art they are
interested in thinking about where they
stack up against other people I think
that that's an appeal that's the appeal
and I think that's most people I think
most people when they again I think most
people are relatively competitive I
think that it's just like okay you're
gonna ask a question I'm compelled like
human nature compels me to give you an
answer and to try to give you that
answer before somebody else does I was
laying in bed I think I was laying in
bed and just thought popped into my head
I don't know why maybe I was reading
something on reddit about Jeopardy and I
was like unrelated to what I was reading
I was like why is it formatted
that you answer you don't answer a
question you respond to an answer with a
question so I looked at up because I
couldn't formulate a guess I I couldn't
figure out why that would be the case
did you formulate a question so
according to the Smithsonian in 1963
television host and erstwhile actor Merv
Griffin was flying back to New York City
with his wife Julianne after a weekend
visiting her parents in Michigan didn't
need to add that but they did Merv was
looking at notes for a new game show and
Julianne asked if it was one of the
knowledge based games she likes so is it
a trivia game he said since the $64,000
question the network won't let you do
those anymore
he said the rigging scanner of the
1950's like that that movie quiz show
yeah which is very good movie
yeah the scandals had killed off
American quiz show seemingly for good
and he said they suspect you of giving
them the answers and she said something
to the effect of well why don't you give
them the answers and people make up the
questions and he's like thinking about
he's like okay
the answer is 5280 and he thought for a
moment the question is how many feet in
a mile and he's like the answer is 79
wistful Vista and in the response was
weirded fibber McGee and Molly live on a
who fibber McGee is this this is in 1963
those two simple questions change TV
history today you have it it was just a
it was just a simple response but it was
such a it was a hook and then I'm like
thinking well if you give an answer it
could you could ask multiple questions
to get that answer so then I'm realizing
that you've got to you also have to
satisfy the category right so it you got
to satisfy the clue in the category so
if it's like there was one that was
Patrick Roy and Hope Solo played this
position
and the category was 10 letter words 10
letter words yeah and the ants
goalkeeper what is goal what is a
goalkeeper wrong what is a goalie
goalkeeper is 10 letters but they had
the they said it had to contain the word
10 so the correct answer was goaltender
oh I had to contain out this yeah great
but they said that so there's my little
trivia associated with jeopardy and I
mean we that's great though what you
just did is great that's what makes it
so great yeah I mean and I don't think I
said mind game when they were
brainstorming it on the plane I don't
think they knew the full ramifications
sometimes you just like what if what if
we give the answer and you have to come
up with a question and then you play it
out ultimately they're just asking a
question you're giving the answer but
they just reverse the sort of the
pretense now
of course we got to talk about Alex
Trebek has got pancreatic cancer as of
the recording of this sending much love
to Alex Alec oh I like send it to the
right person Alec
he's got pancreatic cancer which of
course is like you know what it is Alex
yeah yeah hold on
it's not Alec it's Alec Baldwin you say
I was sending it to the right person and
then you Alex Trebek I was like I kept
faith here's a here's that here's the
dais Alex here's the thing up until
literally like I've never thought that
his name was Alex until like a split
second a second ago when you said Alex
I've always known it to be Trebek I just
have a way of making you may sound wrong
that's a gameshow making true things
sound false
he's got pancreatic cancer and which is
like you know he made it very very low
survival rate money to heart-wrenching
he made the video and they haven't said
who's gonna replace him but what's the
latest though because I don't know what
the status of his health is right now I
don't know the status of his health but
in terms of they're not
Sene who would replace him I think that
you know they're keeping all that under
wraps but um maybe a guy named Alec I
feel like if he has a son
I think his son should do it and I think
that his son should look just like him
but have the moustache that he had in
the 80s and we don't know I mean he
could be he could he could beat this
illness but he's mean he's going to
retire at some point she heartless
rumors are saying that Gayle King will
replace him somehow that names floating
around was her saying he signed off for
the summer but he intends on coming back
because he's saying you know I'm gonna
beat this but then even when he retires
like like you know we wish we wish Alex
the best and we we believe he can do it
the way I wouldn't want to host the way
that you said it somehow tricked my
brain into thinking that it was Alec
that's incredible you have a gift man
thank you
well so we but we've covered we've
covered your number I got to go with my
ooh my number two because Hollywood
Squares my number one my number two is
press your luck because that was nice
that was my favorite show no whammies no
whammies no whammies stop yeah that was
an honorable mention for me it was it
was it was very manic Peter Tomarken was
the host and this guy had the slighest
grin it was like he knew something and I
never figured out what it was and I
couldn't stop watching because I thought
maybe I'd figure it out like he knew
something about life and it was very
amusing to him like something about this
like weird bemused bravado was just I
don't know I just thought he was the
coolest guy torque him to market to
market Peter to market I can't picture
him right and they would have they'd
have the animations on the screen where
the whammies would come out or the yeah
there's a little devil looking devil
guys would come as my Tasmanian devil it
would do different stuff and we talked
on GMM about one of our most viewed
episodes ever was writer game show
cheaters and the guy on price is right
who was the cheater he died recently and
I was it back in the news
Flanigan sent that to us
I don't know why that video kept getting
like tens of millions of views on our
Channel it's crazy people just but we
also talked about cheaters the guy who
cheated on press your luck and like he
knew the patterns and could like hit a
good time at the right time I just like
the energy of it it was just and they
would like they would make them they
would make it look like the contestants
and the hosts were perched on top of
this huge board yeah it was the way they
was a game show that had then they did
this with bumper stuffers too if I
remember the the display of it was like
a picture-in-picture thing yeah it was
just very interesting but I basically
it's my number two just because of his
Peter Tomarken vibe the animations and
just the overall just the energy I don't
remember what the point of the show the
vibe of the show it was like what was
the point of the show I win money but
you're pressing your luck and you're
like I'm gonna go again I mean yeah you
this thing and then you would um it
would it would build up the pressure
would build up in terms of like are you
gonna lose all this money
okay so measure number two yeah so we
don't agree on the number one you said
Hollywood Squares I said family feud
honorable mentions that we didn't
mention that you may remember street
smarts
remember street smarts this is like I'm
[ __ ] early 2000s that seemed trashy to
me but I don't remember what it is it
was well it was it was a game there was
a host can't remember his name who would
go out on the street and do man on the
street interviews with people and then
there was two contestants and they had
to predict if this person was like of
these three contestants that you just
would just introduce you to like which
one of them will know who this is and
they hold up a picture and it's like
Frank Sinatra and it's just like okay
which one of these people only one of
them knew who Frank Sinatra was which
one was and so then you pick one of the
three people and isn't profiling and
then they show you and they say and just
for fun let's see what Carla said and
she doesn't know who Frank Sinatra is so
she says like the President or something
man on the street making fun of stupid
people which is like what now Jimmy
Kimmel has turned into
like a bit with his man on the street
stuff where it's like what do people
know about current politics or whatever
it was very trashy one of my honorable
mentions was supermarket sweep I don't
know why as a kid I had any business
being interested in supermarkets it's
funny because you were so averse at
spending money and have always been but
yet you want that wasn't somebody else
go do it oh yeah wish fulfillment like
oh my gosh if I had a cart in you know
90 seconds what would I get and I think
on Nickelodeon there was a show where
you would go into like Toys R Us and do
the same thing you gonna toy store that
makes sense but yeah I would watch the
adult version supermarket sweep
speaking of Nickelodeon double-dare was
on there yeah double dare top 5 but it
was it's it's so iconic my honorable
mention was funhouse the Fox television
show ripoff of double dare with uh the
host was had red hair and he was he's
been he's been the host of other things
- can you google the host of funhouse I
never heard of it just picture a ripoff
of double dare and that beat double dare
for you I think it had bigger obstacle
courses that were more like um it was
more like American Ninja Warrior in some
ways I think in the final JD Roth was
the host and then I had the newlywed
show and a dating game kind of before
our time but so but yeah reruns and then
those clips pop up a bush but it's just
one of those things that like endless
fodder for compilations tic-tac-dough
never heard of it wink Martindale hosted
that it was tic-tac-toe like Hollywood
Squares but it was um different in ways
I can't remember but a wink Martindale
yeah I mean he hosted a bunch of shows
and he was uh he was hokey but I liked
him you got any other honorable mentions
you're done I'm done with Moe you're
done I shout out the $25,000 pyramid
Dick Clark I like that you'd have you'd
have a celebrity paired so good show
with a with a contestant and it would be
things like
crystal ball a magic 8-ball
round things magic round things
fortune-teller magic things we suck at
this
a prognosticator a pass prophecy it was
things that predict the future things
that predict the future
yeah and then some people would be
really good at it not us there was some
celebrities who didn't have any better
to do they stayed on the show I can't
and then they would get really good at
it right yeah it's good everything try
to bring that back right I don't know
but they should again I think that's I
think that's all in my honorable
mentions concentration that was the last
one that I added you would you'd move
you'd saw it was like a matching gaming
you would remove matching panels it
would reveal a pictograph underneath
that that's much like a phrase and you
had to solve it solve the phrase using
the pictographs I loved that game for
some reason so that's it
yeah those those from a green simple so
we agree on family few simple games like
that just won't take it they won't put
them on television anymore well there's
a whole network they'll put them until
they put them on television in Australia
you know based on what I was there but
there you have it our top game shows of
all times let us not all time we only
have one time go to hashtag ear biscuits
let us know your favorite game show and
tell us why maybe you'll change our
minds maybe you'll remind us of
something or give us a reason or a piece
of trivia that will make us change our
top 5 and linked do you have a wreck you
have a wreckin effect I do
i I got a wreck in effect since you're
done listening this podcast maybe you
want another podcast to listen to before
your biscuits rolls around next week cuz
you're fully caught up I'm gonna
recommend a podcast where you can let
into my wife talk for an hour
Wow our good friend Mike has a podcast
called ask science Mike I highly
recommend his podcast in general but
episode 180 called
living I wrote it down here because I
didn't remember exactly living with a
brain injury with Christy Neil who's my
wife I don't know that I've ever
actually shared specifically that almost
three years ago Christy suffered a brain
injury she she suffers from post
concussion syndrome as a result of a
concussion she had almost three years
ago which dramatically changed her life
as well as had ramifications for us as a
family and I invited you know we've been
talking about when was the right time
maybe for her to come on the air
biscuits and talk about it but it was
she didn't really she didn't want to do
it because of the video component
honestly she wasn't quite ready for that
you know she doesn't love being on the
videos at this point but so asked
science Mike check that out episode 180
especially if you know someone who's had
a concussion or has suffered from an
invisible injury that impacts your life
I think there's lots of takeaways and
I'm super proud of her for everything
she shared I think it's tremendously
power it can be really powerful to
someone who's going through it or know
someone who is so so check that out and
I think that's all I have to say about
it at this time I do think that it's at
some point maybe she'll come on here we
can unpack it further but that's a great
place to start so check it out and with
that being said we will see you again
or you will hear us again or hear and
see us again however you enjoy this next
week in the meantime connect with us the
password is no whammies to watch more
ear biscuits click on the playlist on
the right to watch the previous episode
of your biscuits click on the playlist
to the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]